you
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar a case study of protein sample
prep strategies for membrane proteins
our presenter today is dr. Barbara
keyboards senior research and
development manager protein biology
Thermo Fisher Scientific I'm Kristy
jewel of Labatt's and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by thermo
Fisher Scientific to learn more about
our sponsor please visit thermo Fisher
com
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
sound at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by using that ask a question box
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I now
present today's speaker dr. Barbara
cobourg dr. Coe Board is a senior
research and development manager of the
protein preparation group at Thermo
Fisher Scientific where her team is
responsible for the development of
numerous protein extraction
stabilization purification and cleanup
products for complete biography on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
dr. keyboard you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the kind introduction and
welcome to all of you who are joining us
online for this presentation to start
off let's look at a high-level overview
of today's talk where I'll start with
the description of the five steps what
to consider as you're strategizing your
protein prep procedure followed by a
case study in which I'll discuss our
approach to prepping g-protein coupled
receptors or GPCRs for activity and
structural analyses at the end there
will be some time reserved for questions
so what are the five steps in prepping a
protein to prep a protein from cultured
cells or tissue of any type of for any
type of in vitro analysis the process
starts with making a slice ate or
extract this can be either a whole cell
lysate to soluble eyes all proteins or
some type of sub cellular fractionation
where different cellular compartments
such as membrane nuclei or other
organelles are differentially
solubilized with detergents or separated
by differential centrifugation during
the extraction process whether the
compartment integrity is often
compromised potentially exposing your
protein of interest to proteases and
spaces that are normally sequestered
elsewhere and essential components than
of any lysis buffer formulation is a
mixture of protease and ER phosphatase
inhibitors to preserve the integrity of
the solubilized proteins as well as
preserving any labile post translational
modifications that may have occurred
naturally in situ
second purification or enrichment of
some kind is usually desired this can be
done in a variety of formats involving
chromatography resins and columns or
magnetic beads and magnetic separators
affinity purification is usually the
preferred approach and a variety of
ligands are available to facilitate this
and I'll discuss this in more detail
shortly
classical chromatography resins such as
strong cations or strong anion are also
vital to many purification schemes
so once you have your purified protein
fraction some sort of cleanup is
beneficial both dialysis devices and
desalting resins are frequently used to
remove unwanted chromatography salts and
small molecules that might have been
used to competitively elude protein from
affinity supports as well as to exchange
proteins into a buffer more suitable for
long term storage protein concentrators
and di'ja filtration can also be used
for this purpose in addition to their
more obvious function of concentrating
proteins for more stable storage step
four of the protein prep work flow is
quantitation after all that work how
much protein did yield from your
purification process multiple protein
assays exist to help answer this
question BCA in Kumasi protein assays
being the most popular lastly the fifth
step detection is important to the
workflow since it is here that you
determine qualitatively how well your
protein prep work sds-page Western
blotting and/or mass spectrometry are
often used to evaluate protein size
integrity and verify the identity of the
protein isolated as well as the presence
or identity of any remaining
contaminants
so how do you start the protein
preparation procedure you choose is
largely dictated by the nature of the
sample by the cellular localization
location of the protein you're isolating
how much protein you need to perform
your assays and most importantly the
identity the identity of those
downstream assays and applications so
what do you want to do with your protein
in the end applications such as Western
blotting or mass spectrometry do not
necessarily require a lot of protein nor
do they require your protein you be
functionally active in most cases anyway
while applications like Eliza's immuno
precipitations reporter assays and
activity assays require the protein to
be in its native conformation and
stabilized
the next few slides we'll walk through
some of the factors to consider when
designing your protein prep workflow
such as choosing an expression system
what if any epitope tag to design into
your starting DNA construct how to best
extract or solubilize your protein of
interest do you need to enrich your
purify that protein and if you do need
to purify than at what scale and what
supports are available these factors and
decisions will then be highlighted in
the context of our project that aims to
solubilize stabilize and purify GPCRs
for activity and structural biology
applications
to start off let's back up and take a
quick look at the basic model systems
for overexpressing proteins the
assumption here is that you're over
expressing a recombinant protein not
isolating and endogenously Express
protein so the options are starting at
the top a cell-free system which is
essentially an open system requiring no
live cultures it consists of a
specialized lipase made from e-coli
wheat germ rabbit reticulocyte or
mammalian cell culture cell sources and
is often used in a high-throughput
format and is good for expressing small
amounts of proteins it's challenge is
that large-scale expression is is
usually much more difficult the
workhorse of expression system is
bacteria and that's because this system
is nice and that it's scalable is
relatively low cost it's required simple
cultured conditions and the expression
time is usually short in duration there
may be some issues though with
expressing certain proteins and bacteria
some proteins are not soluble in this
system there are minimal post
translational modifications added to the
expressed proteins in bacteria and some
mammalian proteins may just not express
well so another option is to go to a
yeast system which is also low cost and
simple it does have the advantage of
having able to conduct eukaryotic
protein processing but vermin
fermentations are required - excuse me -
to produce very high yields and growth
requirements may need to be optimized
insect cell cultures are also low cost
they have an advantage of that p2 the
post translational modifications or PTMs
are similar to mammalian systems and
they're good for to express proteins
that are normally toxic to mammalian
cells there's a culture and conditions
are a little bit more demanding and the
PTM
are not quite identical to mammalian
systems so the gold standard then really
is for expressing mammalian proteins
anyway is it a mailing expression system
as this will provide the highest level
of correct post translational
modifications and provide the highest
probability of obtaining fully
functional human proteins the downside
is that the culturing conditions are
more demanding and that high yields are
best achieved with suspension cultures
so if we look at this next slide I've
outlined three different commercial
expression systems that have been
adapted to grow to high density and
suspension eliminating the need for the
end-user to do this and optimize to
obtain maximal yield from a million and
insect cultured cells cumin 293 cell
system was developed especially for
end-users performing structure function
studies that require native protein
folding and post translational
modifications cho or chinese hamster
ovary cells are the workhorse of
biopharma as many biologics are
expressed in show both systems generate
high protein yields of up to one to
three grams per liter more recently an
optimized insect cell or SF system has
been developed to provide cost-effective
platforms for academics as well as
biopharma doing vaccine development so
once you've identified or chosen your
expression system is there any type of
affinity handle that you would like to
engineer into your construct to
facilitate purification so if we start
at the top iMac tags are the most
popular and relatively easy to use at
our low cost hiss tags are pretty much
ubiquitous in the protein purification
world however there one drawback is that
the affinity of this interaction is
lower than the other tag choices and
background contamination is usually
higher as there are more metal
interacting proteins in life sites
however this is still the most popular
choice for purification tag
gft has a higher affinity but it is also
a larger more bulky addition to any
protein its advantages that it can
improve solubility of proteins
especially in e.coli systems as can
other another tag MVP or multiples
binding protein small peptide tags have
the advantage of a small size like the
his pigs but the affinity with their
corresponding antibody supports is
orders of magnitude higher enabling much
cleaner protein preps the disadvantage
is cost of these resins and minimal
reuse and regeneration
however these tags are really popular
for amino precipitations and are often
used for larger scale purifications when
imac resin just doesn't cut it with
respect to purity in addition the flag
tag has a built-in enter a kinase
cleavage site which provides another
strategy for eluding from columns and
makes the tag removal from the
n-terminal take proteins easy
so since his tags are popping
I wanted to take a brief amount of time
to discuss some options for the
corresponding iMac resins used to purify
them the schematic on the Left shows the
inverse relationship with protein yields
and purity as a function of metal ion
nickel is the most popular version of
iMac as it strikes a good balance
between purity and yield if purity is a
major concern then cobalt supports are
best with a caveat of potentially
compromising a bit unyielding points
between the key later on the resin and
the metal also influences purity lower
number of coordination sites result in
higher protein capacities but are also a
bit dirtier NTA is the most popular key
later as it provides good capacity while
being fairly resistant to the effects of
other chemical entities in the light
safe and binding buffer the Pens
identity later shown on the bottom here
is highly specialized in that it is
resistant to reducing agents EDTA and
other amino acids are metabolites in
cell culture media but has a drawback of
a lower binding capacity in most
situations so one other tag that I
wanted to comment on is that is the flag
tag or the Dyk d4k epitope tag this is
an extremely popular tag as its small
minimizing any potential interference
with the overexpress protein and it
interact strongly with its corresponding
immobilized antibody resin resulting in
very high purity protein preparation
it's a great tag and while I highly
recommend the use of this tag I wanted
to draw your attention to a potential
issue when using this tag with membrane
protein expression constructs especially
since the case study presented later in
this talk features membrane receptors
there are a couple of reports in the
literature where flag tag was used to
tag trans membrane and secreted proteins
but the authors were not able to
efficiently purify these proteins and
the problem found was that the tyrosine
residue in the sequence was sulfated in
the golgi especially with n-terminal tag
placements the sulfation modification of
the tyrosine interferes with the
recognition of the epitope tag by some
of the anti plague antibodies available
so if you use the flag epitope tag on
overexpress membrane proteins and can't
successfully purify it on anti flag
supports is likely not a problem with
the chromatography resin or the beads so
it's best to be safe by choosing a
different epitope tag for membrane or
secreted proteins
so choosing a your extraction strategy
is also dependent largely on downstream
applications and these may influence the
choice for example if you're
characterizing proteins modifying
labeling them or determining their
structure purification is usually
required so starting with prepared by
preparing a simple whole cell lysate
extraction is usually the easiest
starting point other applications such
as protein interaction assays monitoring
disease states tracking biomarkers or
studying cell signaling Cascades may be
accomplished without purification but
may benefit from some type of enrichment
to help increase the effective
concentration of the desired protein in
Richmond is often accomplished by
differential detergent solubalization of
cell compartments using specialized cell
fractionation buffers
so these most purification strategies
begin to the wholesale lysis buffer
optimized for the model organism used to
express the protein there are lysis
buffers optimized for mammalian
bacterial or yeast cells maximizing the
total amount of protein soluble eyes
while still being gentle enough to
maintain native structure and function
and some of these are listed in the
middle column of the table on the right
alternatively there are buffers and
formulations that enable nuclear
bioplasmic fractionation membrane
protein enrichment or other sub cell
fractionation providing methods to
enrich for protein classes or particular
cellular locations the extraction buffer
that I will discuss later in this talk
that was used to solubilize GPCRs has
characteristics of both types of lysis
buffers and that it results in
essentially the production of a whole
cell lysate but it is specialized as
well and that it is able to stabilize a
certain subset of proteins the GPCRs
so getting back to our five steps if
purification is required what scale of
purification is needed and what
chromatography support is best for the
job as you can see there are multiple
options at any scale magnetic beads and
small-scale spin columns are best for
nanogram to microgram quantities for
example to do IPS and pull-downs
magnetic agarose can be used as an
automatable alternative to small auto
rows columns for milligram to about a
gram of protein larger research scale
purifications requiring F PLC columns
work best with cross-linked agarose or
SuperFlow resins lastly porous resins
are type of bioprocess media that enable
high flow rate large volume bio process
scale purifications but I won't really
discuss anymore of that type of resin at
length in this talk
if automated purification is desired
there are two main types of magnetic
supports traditional low micron-sized
magnetic particles and larger
high-capacity and magnetic agarose the
latter being porous and providing a much
larger binding capacity because of this
higher capacity magnetic I girls can be
used to automate small-scale
purifications I can also be used to
screen expression levels during
optimization experiments
so moving on almost everyone prefers the
speed and efficiency of a fini
purification over classical
chromatography many of these ligands
especially those to purify tagged
recombinant proteins are available on
both chromatography resins as well as
metic beads classical resins such as
cation and exchange resins hydrophobic
interaction resins etc still have their
place when purifying endogenous proteins
which have no overexpression tag or as a
polishing step after affinity
chromatography to maximize purity by
removing small trace levels of
contaminants
so now we'll apply some of these
fundamentals to solubilizing and
purifying gpcrs to be used in downstream
activity assays and cryo-em structural
studies
so I probably don't need to tell many in
this audience the importance of membrane
proteins but as listed here they're
involved in a variety of cellular
functions ranging from intercellular
junctions to cell-cell recognition cell
attachment and thematic activity and
signal transduction and thus they are
critical for normal cell homeostasis and
any aberrant signaling that can have
serious consequences and manifest as a
variety of disease states
g-protein-coupled receptors or GPCRs are
seven alpha helical transmembrane domain
proteins that play important roles in
transmitting cell signals across the
plasma membrane there are over a
thousand different GPCRs encoded by the
human genome making them the largest
class of membrane proteins they serve as
effective drug targets variety of
genetic enemies system disorders as
shown here on the right and they serve
as potential biomarkers and therapeutic
targets for cancer treatment there are
currently at least 475 drugs approved by
the FDA that act on over a hundred
unique gpcrs one of the main challenges
in GPC our research is the ability to
efficiently extract the receptor from
the membrane without compromising the
structural and functional integrity of
the receptor in order to study it
isolating and studying GPCRs presents
many challenges their complexity makes
them hard to clone and Express they are
embedded in the plasma membrane making
extraction difficult and the efficient
extraction often requires harsh
conditions that result in denatured or
unstable proteins and loi any kind of
activity assay then usually needs to be
done right away offer components that
may help to stabilize gpcrs outside of
the cell membrane often are found and
interfere with downstream analyses for
example detergents and glycerol are not
compatible with mass spec or structural
studies such as cryo am this case study
that follows is is a work in progress we
don't have all the answers yet but we're
making significant progress in
addressing some of these challenges
especially in extracting a stabilizing
GPCRs maintaining functions throughout
the initial purification process and
working to minimize contaminants and
substances that may interfere downstream
most of the emphasis will be on the
first three steps of the protein prep
process extraction and preservation
purification and cleanup
there are several strategies to extract
GPCRs from both cells and tissues
subcellular fractionation uses one or
more of the properties of membrane
proteins such as density surface size
and shapes to separate them based on
differential centrifugation in media of
high viscosity such as sucrose or
sorbitol aqueous polymer two phase
system is a liquid liquid fractionation
technique high salt or high pH buffers
can be used to dissociate proteins from
the cell membrane but can also damage
protein integrity so most of these
traditional protocols are laborious time
consuming and require extensive ultra
centrifugation equipment as well as
extra steps to stabilize the target
protein for these reasons we decided to
focus on detergent extraction and like
the components of biological membranes
detergents have both hydrophobic
associating properties and polar head
groups that allow the dispersion of
hydrophobic compounds into solution at
high concentrations detergent monomers
aggregate in the structures called
micelles and working at or above the
critical micelle concentration or CMC
for most detergent monomers to form
colloidal aggregates or my cells that
can sequester hydrophobic membrane
proteins into their structures
effectively keeping them in solution for
obvious reasons we wanted to avoid using
denaturing detergents such as SDS as
these would not be ideal for maintenance
of both structure and function of gpcrs
so we decided to focus on non denaturing
detergents for extraction after testing
a variety of detergents including
several of those listed here in this
table we determined that a mixture of
mana ionic and zwitterionic detergent
give the best results when extracting
GPCRs
not only do we want to fully solubilize
the GPCRs but they also need to maintain
their native form and function
afterwards as integral membrane proteins
they are generally unstable when we when
removed from their membrane environment
different strategies for stabilization
include Protea lives which are systems
that mimic lipid membranes and
incorporates the protein within
nano discs which are nanometer scale
planar discs of bilipid layer stabilized
by an encircling scaffold protein next
the small approach is similar to Nana
disc and that it involves the
spontaneous encapsulation of proteins
from a membrane into a wrapped now scale
particle but instead of a protein
scaffold styrene maleic acid wraps the
protein lipid particles
alcohol's our short answer Pathak
polymer is designed to absorb tightly
after the hydrophobic surface of the
transmembrane proteins and covers them
with a thin interfacial layer of
surfactants and lastly the inclusion of
sterols stabilizes by interacting
directly with the GPC are encapsulated
within a micelle the approach commonly
found in the literature is the first
extractive gpcrs from the membrane
followed by a separate step to stabilize
the extractive receptor we determined
however that the receptor is better
stabilized if both the extraction and
the stabilization happened concurrently
because of this we developed an
all-in-one formulation that contains all
of the components needed to extract
stable and functional GPCRs so not only
did we want it all in one formulation
but we also wanted to optimize the
extraction protocol to be fast and
efficient so this slide outlines the
basic protocols so if you follow the
numerical sequence starting with your
sample whether that be tissue or cells
you wash your sample in cold PBS pin it
down discard the wash and then we
suspend the resulting pellet in GPC our
extraction and stabilization reagent
suspended and incubate it for 30 minutes
at 4 degrees following the incubation
the cell debris is pelleted by
centrifugation at 16,000 times G for 20
minutes and from there you'll remove the
supernatant containing the functional
receptor and proceed to either purifying
your tagged receptor from the whole cell
lysate or taking your extract directly
into your downstream application so some
of the common downstream applications or
assays for GPCRs include if you start at
the top the slide amino acids ligand
binding assays surface plasmon resonance
functional assays such as GT began mass
exchange assays structural studies such
as NMR x-ray crystallography or cryo
a.m. and thermal shift assays
initially we wanted to show that we were
able to efficiently soluble eyes
endogenous ly Express gpcrs from both
culture cells and tissues so the Western
blot on the Left shows three different
GPCRs extracted from two different cell
lines using four different extraction
strategies these approaches included two
different detergent free membrane
preparations a and B and two detergent
based extraction buffers
both detergent approaches were more
efficient of soluble izing the various
gpcrs if you compare that soluble or s
labeled lane to the pee or pellet Lane
these are more efficient at sizing than
the detergent free methods with the
optimized gpcr reagent which is sample C
being equal to or better than the
harsher Rippa buffer in sample D similar
results were observed with the liver and
brain tissue samples on the right
next we wanted to demonstrate that what
we isolated was functionally active and
and we did this by initially using
radioligand binding assays the show
specifically and binding to the receptor
extracted GPCRs were incubated with
treaty aided ligand specific for the
respective GPC our unbound ur free
ligand was removed using a small
molecule removal resin and GPC our
samples in the flow-through
were counted in a liquid scintillation
counter
our first trial is with the m3 receptor
in the left panel the Western blot shows
99% of the receptor expressed in choked
a1 cells with soluble eyes using the GPC
our extraction reagent both with and
without the stabilizing component this
shows that the stabilizer itself does
not aid in extraction but looking at the
activity data in the middle panel you
can see that the initial binding
activity is about to fold higher when
the stabilizer is present during the
initial extraction so if you look at the
dark bars in the middle top graph the
presence of the stabilizer is absolutely
required to maintain active receptor
during storage at 4 degrees over 10 days
or at up to 1 month at -20 C you see
that in this case storage of those
receptors remain stable and retain
greater than 75 percent of the initial
activity
this reagent adds significant
flexibility with respect to time and
allows for follow-up experiments that
would normally require a new preparation
on a day for each assay
additional receptor activity assays were
performed to show that the gpcr
extraction and stabilization reagent was
able to efficiently extract different
GPCRs from stable expression cell lines
as well as tissue the right panel shows
the stabilizing benefits of the reagent
for the adora 2a or a2 AR activity
during prolonged storage at 4c so for up
to two weeks you can see that activity
was make successful e maintained
a new and promising tool in membrane
research is the detergent free
solubilization of membrane proteins by
styrene maleic acid copolymers or SMAS
these amphipathic molecules are able to
solubilize lipid bilayers in the form of
nano discs that are bound by the polymer
so membrane proteins can be directly
extract from the cells in a water
soluble form while conserving a patch of
native membrane around them so this
slide will show two protocols so on our
left is our current protocol and on the
right we have a sample small SMA LP
protocol in which we tried both the lipo
disk lipid formulations and an amp of
poly agent to surround and stabilize the
GPCR when and which is then wrapped by
the styrene maleic acid assembly so both
methods are relatively straightforward
with a small protocol being slightly
more involved with respect to reagents
and time required
but one of the results have to say so we
wanted to compare both the
solubilization and the stabilization
properties of the small and GPCR reagent
approaches the extraction results for
two receptors the glutamate receptor and
the beta 2 AR receptor are shown in the
western blots on the top left panel
extraction efficiency was similar or
better with the gpcr agent compared to
either smoke method adenosine receptor
2a or a dora to a was solubilized from
mouse brain tissue with the whole cell
lysate method and the GPCR agent for the
smoke method using either lipo disk 3.1
or amp of paul for polymer stabilization
radial ligand binding as a phase show
that the extracts made with the GPC are
extraction and stabilization reagent of
greater than twofold specific activity
from endogenously expressed a to AR when
compared to the small preps
so in this case
all methods were able to extract all
methods were able to stabilize but the
GPCR reagent performed at least choices
as well so moving on now to purifying
these extracted gpcrs we previously
validated that the reagent was able to
efficiently extract and stabilize the
activity ultimately we want to extract
purify and stabilize for downstream
structural analysis by cryo a.m. so we
created a construct to express a GPC are
either the a2 AR or the cb2 receptor as
a fusion with gfp followed by his tag on
the c-terminus since these GPCRs are
mammalian in origin we chose to express
in the X P 2 9 3 system to better our
chances of generating correctly folded
highly active protein next we then
diluted the extract 1 to 10 in the
nickel imac binding buffer
we wanted to keep the GPCR reagent
components present at about 1 1 times
the CFC concentration in order to keep
the membrane protein soluble and stable
throughout the purification but minimize
any potential detergent interferences
following Ellucian imidazole was removed
using ziba desalting column and the GPC
are analyzed by SDS page quantified by
protein assay and analyzed for
activities by radio ligand binding assay
we were we were initially surprised when
we checked the extraction efficiency of
the overexpress gpcrs in the higher
expressing XP to 93 system while the
GPCR reagent normally soluble is greater
than 90% of the endogenous or lower
level expressed gpcrs we Sol utilize the
significantly lower percentage when the
gpcr was in a more highly expressed
system we tried adding a bit of
mechanical disruption to enhance the
action of the extraction reagent and
found the gentle down homogenous asian
bore sonication increase the amount of
gpcr in the soluble fraction which is
shown on the Left panel
however activity assays show that while
more protein was solubilized with
sonication the highest activity was
obtained with a gentler dump mechanical
disruption and that is data shown on the
right in all methods they were still
GPCR in the insoluble fraction and we
hypothesize that the membrane fluidity
or composition is slightly altered with
higher levels of expression and that
makes the membrane more resistant to
solubilization thus additional
mechanical disruption may be required in
these situations it is also possible
that the overexpress GPCR that remains
insoluble may not be material that you
actually want to use as it may be
improperly folded or abrogated
so taking the
gpcr and purifying it over nickel nta
agarose or magnetic agarose according to
the work flow described in a previous
slide we show that we can purify the CB
to GFP fusion the Western blot on the
right confirms the identity and the size
of the isolated construct and that it
was efficiently captured and eluded from
the iMac purification support if you
look at the lanes marked e4 Ellucian the
silver stain gel on the left is a bit
busier to look at and harder to see the
target protein but it does show that
while the CB 2 is present in the
aleutian another purification step will
be required to remove residual
contaminants either a dual affinity tag
will be used in the future or an ion
exchange polishing step
similar results were seen with the
adenosine receptor construct Western
blots on the right show good binding and
illusion from the nickel nta magnetic
agarose beads whether you're detecting
with the a2 AR antibody itself or an
antibody against the gfp or the his tag
the silver stain on the Left shows
overall purity and the residual
contaminants that that remain
or the real question is is that the
horror optimized further optimizing the
purification we wanted to check the
ligand binding activity activity of the
a to a our receptor after the nickel
imac purification the data shows that
the identity and binding activity was
retained throughout the purification
which is good and that the a to a our
specific binding activity was
significantly enhanced in the purified
and eluded fraction we are confident
that we can maintain active protein
throughout the purification workflow as
long as we retain low concentration of
the initial GPC our extraction and
stable loop Disney stabilisation
components throughout the course of the
purification so to wrap up what have we
talked about first of all we talked a
little bit about protein preparation
workflows and how they're largely
influenced by the number and nature of
the downstream applications and analyses
that you want to perform there are
multiple techniques for solubilizing
stable GPCRs optimized detergents
extraction can improve the entire
protein prep work flow for endogenous
receptors from extraction through
detection
for overexpressed receptors some gentle
means of mechanical disruption is often
required to augment detergent extraction
methods and using a combination of
detergent and stabilizer during
extraction greatly increases the
stability of extractor receptors and
allows for extended storage at either
four degrees or minus 20
this combination of detergent stabilizer
is required throughout the purification
process to maintain receptor function
and GPCR solubilized using the detergent
stabilizer extraction method with the
Pierce gpcr extraction stabilization
reagent gilmour functional receptors
compared to other polymer techniques
such as small synapses Falls lastly I
just wanted to reiterate the five steps
in the protein preparation workflow
starting with extraction preservation
purification cleanup quantitation and
detection and I've highlighted a few of
the critical reagents and tools used to
generate the data that I showed here
today so I'd like to thank my scientists
and collaborators who helped generate
the samples of the overexpression
samples as well as the extraction and
purification data that you've seen here
today and at this point I'd be happy to
take any questions you may have
thank you doctor keyboard for that
excellent presentation as you mentioned
it is now time for our live Q&A portion
of our webinar now to our audience if
you have any questions you would like to
ask please do so now just click on that
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for it okay
let's get started
we already have some great questions
coming in dr. keyboard let's begin with
this one why did you choose XV 293 to
express the gpcr constructs
okay it's a good question so as I
mentioned is the GPC ours were mammalian
in origin so we wanted to match the
expression system to that but also what
you know researchers in the field have
been finding is that as you extract the
gpcrs a little bit of the endogenous
lipids from the originating membrane
come along for the ride as you either
create micelles or some of these nano
nano disk particles and that those
endogenous lipids are actually critical
for functions so the best way to stack
the deck and hope that you isolate
active receptor is to express it in the
native system as well as give it a
chance to bring some native lipids along
for better activity
thank you our next question is there a
particular reason why you added GFP into
the CB 2 and the a2 AR context so so yes
the know we had that construct I think
for another another purpose but we
decided to use it because ultimately we
wanted to hopefully
extract and purify protein that could go
into cryo am studies and the larger the
protein in that case the better furnish
obtaining they required resolution by
cryo am so a combination of the GPC are
fused to the GFP creates a larger
protein molecule and then combined into
the the lipid myself or the detergent
micelle excuse me we hope to then create
a large enough structure to see
successfully by cryo am
now dr. keyboard is the background seen
on the silver stage gels of the I'm a
purification normal it is you know if
you have a protein that is really highly
expressed you know like a soluble
protein and you have a big band on a
your starting life eight-lane most of
that protein then that I that all that
protein occupies the space on the
affinity resin okay and there's not room
for a lot of contaminant binding in the
case of the GPC ours that's you know
they even though they're overexpression
systems they still don't over expressed
as dramatically as as other soluble
proteins so some of that is just the
inherent nature of working with membrane
proteins and it being a difficult system
and then some of it is because we we
probably can adjust that the resin to
sample ratio a little bit to maybe
decrease the resin and minimize space
for nonspecific binding
thank you now we have time for just a
few more have you looked at other GPCR
activity essays in interaction assays
with g-proteins
agonist inverse agonist not yet but we
intend to you know to to get that
credibility in the gpcr field we know we
need to do those assays we started with
probably the easier assay to set up
which is the the radioligand binding
assay and so we're we're kind of
screening conditions using that but
ultimately yes we want to show to show
that we've isolated and purified active
functional GPCR we will need to go into
those assays and that's something that
some of our collaborators within the
company are going to help us with
thank you and we'd have to wrap with
this final question how long can you
keep the cell utilized
gpcr stored and stabilized so I show
data for one week at 4°c and up to a
month that -20 AC we have extended those
both studies we found that we can't
really go much beyond one and a half to
two weeks and I think that maybe
somewhat receptor dependent when you're
storing them at four degrees and but we
I think we have our latest data is that
we can go up to potentially two months
at minus 20 so it's it's not
indefinitely but it is significantly
helpful compared to having to isolate
and the receptors and doing all your
assays same day
thank you and thank you again dr. Kapoor
for your time today and for your
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor Thermo
Fisher Scientific for underwriting
today's educational webcast before we go
I want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions that we did not have
time to answer today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by dr. Koh board via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on-demand and mavericks will
alert you via email when it is available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event that's
all for now and we thank you for joining
us hope to see you again soon bye bye